Hey, how's it going bros? My name's-- mynameisjeff
Okay
Welcome back to Outlast, this is not live like last time
Uh, a lot of you guys loved the liv-live episode.
How are you doing baby
Shake that ass for me Miley!
Alright let's watch out for these fucking peasants.
Ain't gonna get me this time--
Alright, whatever.
I don't understand why they have to throw up on me!
Like, what did I ever--Urh no.
You're disgusting-- you're all disgusting.
No.
Alright, let's just go through here really quick!
Very nice!
There we go, we were fine.
Uhh.. I was gonna say,
A lot of people liked live episode but uh, the reason I.. did it was because..
All of my Outlast videos got demonetized. (F U YouTube)
Uncorrectly.
So I wanted to see if I could stream to fix it, but it didn't seem like it made ANY difference.
Soo, here we are, back again.
Myy only friend.
Uhh.
Appreciate all your feedback, it's all good
Good shit. Uhh.
Al-alright I guess we're gonna go in here, I don't know where the fuck to go.
Excellent.
AH!
What the FUCK dude-- wHaT the FUcK is YouR proBlEm?
AsShOlE!
What the fuck, man!
What did I ever do-- heal!
The shit is your problem, mehn!
You better stay in there, boi!
what is this fUcKinG place?
Maybe we can climb underneath?
We can, okay.
Exc-- HWOOO
~BATTERIES~ (WEHNTHEMRNINGSGUNandYOUCANTGOON)
HeLL Yeh.
Let's take t-the FUCK!
Go go go, he's coming in!
BiTcH!
You SKINNY BITCH
Aw what're you gonna do then?
Oh fuck, oh fuck I shouldn't have asked. I shouldn't have asked.
I shouldn't have fucking asked.
Okay, maybe through here.
Here we go, you guys are..
You guys look great-- you don't..just don't touch me alright.
WHOOP!
YEH, BOI!
See ya later, skinny BITCHES-- what is he doing?
That's right.
Best player of Outlast of all time. You're watching the.. zero death playthrough, everyone!
Zero deathsss!
Everyone-- top of the morning dadaa..
Okay. Well..
Seriously, nothing here?
Seriously?
FuCk
So I'm not supposed to be here?
Aw, come on man.
Of course, you just had to fucking jump up!
I keep missin' the most obvious fucking shit in this game.
I'm the worst.
The worst player of this game.
AHHH!
AHH! FUUCK!
FUCK! Ughh!
Helvete.
Oh no, what did I do.
Oh, my glasses.
Uhh where am I.
Heey, this is not so bad.
Who's out there?
Who's creeping in the night.
Let's go this way-- NO.
Shuddap.
Waht?
Oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck, oh shit! Strafe!
strafe! strafe! strafe! strafe!
Ughh!
Aw, this is bad.
Fuck.
Did he just say 'fuck me'?
That's my line!
And also, please don't---
Ahh, they'll never find us.
What are they?
Ohh, it's a little-- HAHAHAHA!
What the fuck is that!
Ahah! ahh!
Oh, oh no. oh no. oh no. oh no. not here.
Nonononono.
You don't wanna come here, boi.
That's right.
The fuck is that thing!
Maybe we can.. crawl through this tent!
yes!
Am I wearing my fucking headphones backward again!?
I was like 'what the fuck!'
I keep wearing these headphones wrong!
Alright, let's just go.
We're good, we're good.
No, don't touch me.
Fuckin' eye patch pirate
Fucking so can-- ahh shit.
That's uh, that's bad. That's really bad.
Well it's fine, I'll just go here.
Why does no one in this game like me??
OH it's a spring here! For fuck's sake! I always miss the obvious things.
Oh, what?
This game is so fucking weird.
Jesus Christ.
Alright, let's go out-- hey ah top of th---
Jessica come back to me, I love you.. you're my child.
What the fuck, she's such an asshole.
What's happening here?
I can't jump over?
This game is too fucking dark man. I can't see anything.
Okay, well I don't know why she's whispering to me.
I don't need you to tell me that.
We got.. Goon Cha and.. Froon Cha.
Woah what the.. oh it's my shadow. Damn, I look buff. Don't I? haha!
Get that protein, boi.
Is that how you.. computer.
Alright we got ar -a Father.
Purs-pur curry.
Feast of The Blessed Virgin Mary.
I took Miss Gray out of phys ed today to have a little talk with her.
Oh.. kay..
Runnin' away, huh?
It just saved.. I don't know if I like that. Ha!
See i'm on top of things.
If this was a real horror game.. I'll be fine, trust me. Trust me I'll be.
I'll be just fine.
I -I -I -I have zero deaths. That's for sure. That's for sure.
Id id id wouldn't have any deaths.
What's up Jesus.
Whatcha doin'. Nice nipples. Gotta say.